welcome to this video playing darts ripe
done the drive from the UK I guess
certainly sets of like okay the noons l
maybe something else not play the
sameish all the time okay he spends the
tempo on age 6 mm preventing Bishop g5
maybe just develop it done is quite
convenient to have this extra move from
age 6 is really not helping him very
much not terribly bad but it might be a
loss of a temple okay let's see what
he's doing now going for something with
d5 I guess no one's playing with be 6 mm
okay let's go with d5 there's um
tactical possibility here takes takes
Knight takes ok he's played age 60 I'm
not taking them and maybe you could have
taken on d5 ok now i'm playing you for
and now we have a typical structure the
huebner structure actually um normally
with the night on e 7 yeah ok let's see
one possible way to place night h4 but
this Sam is not possible now at the
moment because he can move his night so
I'm going to do this reroute the night
is not really good on f3 trying to get
it to e3 that's a good spot or maybe g3
92f form this can also be a good setup
let's see what he's doing ok Knight to
d7 they're probably rook e8 9 f8 to g6
coming so I'm going to put it on g2 this
is normally with g 3 mp3 played also a
good idea maybe f4 here but then he can
take and my porn hangs so not a good
idea let's see how should I play this he
might play the night to g6 may be a
bishop to age three ok yeah with the
rukon yet and the knight on f6 is not so
easy to play a 4 as he probably will
take and take my e4 pawn so I'll just
play this very slow set up the way he
played it is some is very solid of
course but also a bit passive because he
has a hard time to ever player 5
now I need to regroup a bit my g-mail
coming then 2 h 3 i'm not sure the night
is not great down okay let's just
protect the g5 square so that i can just
take it okay so let's see how should i
do this now I can't play g4 actually
here g4 and if he goes back out take on
g5 okay but g4 Knight f6 Bishop g5 HD
525 this Knight takes e4 with a funny
attack on Marik okay so not not really
great you have the night coming to h3 as
is not a real problem I can just move
the rock away my intention is to go to
g2 maybe I can do that with the rook if
Knight f3 is plata and by other ideas of
course to play night at five maybe
yeah 2g two on two how to save I guess
he has better okay to a five this is I
don't really know if this is so great
for black the night on age 3 has
absolutely no square but we will be
difficult for him if I take it
team yeah maybe he can play something
like a 49 f 6 or start with 96 and then
I for one of those counter place might
be a might be still sufficient it's
sometimes it's sometimes the case how do
i attack the night though it's not easy
Bishop everyone and rook moves is very
artificial Queen e2f1 with the rook
something like that okay I want to block
you for relay how do i attack this i
might play g4 okay this was my idea
anyway get the Queen here and maybe
Queen f1 then move the rock okay maybe
you can take and play G for that that's
true very difficult but then aged 6 is
hanging you might play g4 though simply
just like that possible
I can take age 60 tough game it's
amazing that this offside night seems to
seems to seems to still be okay from
black it looks very strange at first
this piece but it seems to be okay still
ok so I'm going to on g4 I going to play
as f fly morning trying to open up
things maybe I could have given the
check first may be tough to play if I go
if he goes efore I think I'm going to
bring the porn wow check I think you
overlook that not sure how how bad it is
for em but check certainly rook age 8
and then then the H file can can be a
problem it's not it's not entirely clear
brook h8 up liking g2 and hope for the
best
how do I counter-attack maybe with a
five maybe do a five or two how to play
here with 40 seconds check I get screen
to h4 wow wow check
yeah that's probably lost him from me
probably hmm it's got G 3m unbelievable
Queen f 2 g-3 but I have no sin leave
anyway oh maybe this is also losing
check check maybe I can still keep keep
it like we were just being an exchange
down maybe check then this situation
isn't even that check check check check
black for fits on town yeah I was always
thinking a rookie 77 is made yeah I
don't know maybe I'm just lost but I
just had seconds on the clock it's
probably not some of it but it was
really messy okay here he could have one
here of course with with g3 here g3 is
just flat winning I all call the check
and then g3 yeah that age five I simply
overlooked Queen h4 I simply overlooked
that the Queen comes to age for this is
losing I must retreat the bishop here
and what the computer is is very relaxed
about all this says White's winning with
93 21 that's not very human very human
way to play it gives this as the winning
line simply check dodging all the checks
here and at the end rookie 7s winning
yeah very difficult very difficult I
mean it's clear that he had he had
overlooked the capture him and the check
chapter this should win somehow d6 is
winning him okay yeah it's just more
forceful g6 he cannot take it because of
rookies on here and rookie 7 is a very
strong threat yeah that's that's just
quicker what I wanted to do is I wanted
to get get out of this book
aight idea and ok it's it should win as
well but oh interesting here Bishop g3
is stronger and enough for the win
interesting this is after night h5 not
clear the direct night h5 comp gives it
a sequel with some some weird perpetual
with Queen B 1 / md5 at the very very
sharp position and clearly we both
cannot player perfectly I a bishop the
two wins but just should lose yeah I
overlooked the Queen comin to h4 chant
yes it's basically beyond saving check
9393 also wins jan check book takes here
and what's the wind night age 50 k night
age 50 k this is very convincing at it
it saves the night and gets in the
counter-attack with night f4 check King
e5 this is winning directly and this now
yeah it's also when she did it it
continues the game 6 chat yeah okay it's
a crap shoot him King g3s a draw
according to the comp King III losses
because of rookie one check okay he
however needed to play instant moves as
well ruga edge five wins and here okay
yeah I'm ranked but we both were playing
gasps we needed to play in Sue's okay
thanks for watching